يتهمهم وزير دفاع بوتين الأجنبي ورئيس
أركان الجيش بقتل
قواته في الوحل عن طريق تجويعهم من
الذخيرة، لم يتبق
لدينا سوى كيلومترين أو نحو ذلك
للاستيلاء عليها من أصل 45. تلقيت إنذارًا لاحقًا
بإرسال ذخيرة وإلا فسوف تسحب قواته
خروج القوات من الوحل الخلفي تمامًا كما كانوا على
وشك الاستيلاء على الأمر
أيضًا مثيرًا للقلق بالنسبة للكرملين سيث
بصفته نائب قائد فاغنر حتى
الأسبوع الماضي كان نائب وزير الدفاع الروسي،
وهو يلمح إلى مواجهة فاغنر
الكرملين المعلقة
يقول المتحدث العسكري الأوكراني إن باتمان يمكن أن يكون في مواجهة
نقطة تحول إذا لم تحل روسيا
مشكلة إمدادات الذخيرة، ويقول أيضًا
إن براغوسيان لا يستطيع تحمل الاستمرار في
خسارة القوات بهذا المعدل إذا فعل ذلك، ويقول
المتحدث إنه سيتم
تدمير فاغنر بريغوسيان، ويقول إنه ليس لديه
خيار سوى سحب
المكائد التي ليس لها أي تأثير.  في
القتال الدائر حول المدينة المدمرة
يوم الجمعة، لا يزال
الجانبان يغذيان الرجال في
الخطوط الأمامية المعروفة باسم مفرمة اللحم الأوكرانية،
والقتال لا يقتصر على ساحة
المعركة في تركيا فحسب، حيث قام دبلوماسي روسي
بتمزيق العلم الأوكراني وسرعان ما تم
لكمه في
مجلس برلماني يهدف إلى  إقناع الجانبين
بالاتفاق على تمديد عمل وكلاء الحبوب في البحر الأسود الذي توسطت فيه الأمم المتحدة.
كما يتوجه الدبلوماسيون الروس
إلى نائب
وزير الخارجية الأمريكي سيرغي ريبيكوف
ليعلن أن الولايات المتحدة وروسيا على
وشك صراع مسلح مفتوح، وهو ما يعد
تصعيدًا إضافيًا لخطاب الكرملين الأخير الذي لا أساس له.
مزاعم بأن الولايات المتحدة
وجهت أوكرانيا إلى إطلاق طائرات بدون طيار
فوق الكرملين في محاولة
لاغتيال الرئيس بوتين، وهو
ادعاء تنفيه كل من كييف وواشنطن
بشكل قاطع.